I told him my name is in Romania is
mihai which means uh Michael it's funny
uh when I went to the US I told
everybody my name was me hi and they
were very I'm high as well you know they
were like very
much
they said you must be the happiest
person on Earth you are high all the
time yeah
I'm going into my stream now and I will
not look at Chad actually because then I
can see your game no is it my game
okay
what you're doing don't listen to that
M3 and
you can hear me if I do once again I
don't really care it's it's if it's
stressful for him it's okay we can do
something else but
no no it's it's no problem here
okay uh show me preludes and corpse
again okay okay so I'm not sure about
this but I'm definitely going some Rush
strategy
so maybe even inventric so do I go with
us I think I do this way it should be
Tarsus
and this is definitely the pick
which is this this and that's pretty
much it maybe I calculate how much do I
need to play so let's say General it's
the thing yeah that's the problem you
really want to play Solita and uh or
Prelude don't really allow it right oh
there's minor three here so that's
that's the same as the city so I can
only keep two cards is what you're
saying yeah but wait wait wait wait
you're taking two titanium with with the
ocean
definitely oh yeah you're right uh so
that's it so that means it's actually
plus three and plus three with the city
so you have 46 cash right you have 46
cash
right no
no that's that's too much
you have only 46 cash after the city
so the equivalent of 46 cash after the
city so you cannot keep four and five
solida it's impossible oh you're right I
would uh
um like this probably
all right maybe not this I'm not sure
I would
I think Sabo has more value than 40.
well probably
all right let's try it like this I think
it makes sense
all right because you have equity for
you have some you have some problems
from Mac with Richard Vines as well so
really you're basically at
you will have to uh
you will have two two heat bumps by gen
3. so
I'm doing my for the fence here what did
you do what did you do
oh no [\h__\h]
I already [\h__\h] up didn't it no yeah
yes you did
foreign
[Music]
oh no
I can take one titanium and I can still
so let's all right three no three no you
can't you can't you can't uh
oh if you yeah yeah you can yeah then do
it
oh my God
laughs
what a disaster
[Music]
you fight too fast here yeah
I was I was like no it's not a problem
30 minutes I can do this I'll just play
first I already make my stance gen one
seems good
[Music]
so uh
but at least I'm I'm being nice to my
opponent so now I'm the not the
sabotaging
yeah
but uh
that's a huge cost
this has a huge cost it really does yeah
um
and we even talked about it we talked oh
we did the math I can just put it to a
titanium which I'm fine yeah oh Leo
this is getting very hot in here
yes
best way to play hellos
yes yes definitely
very straightforward exactly what you
want
he's playing unmi so you're basically
both rushing let's whoever finds the
best fun tags with I don't know this
uh is is it yes does he have power wait
does he have power he does it it does
does he have
what have you done so far
pretty much nothing I played uh
okay
yeah it's probably geothermal but uh
yeah I don't think it matters right
no he probably does I mean it's probably
won't play geothermal he may play
lifetime at some point but
special design for me he's not doing
jovians and it may have value yeah but
do I even keep it I'm thinking just
keeping this that's it yeah you're just
getting this because 19 I couldn't keep
two cards but I don't think I want to go
special designs here
I mean special design is a gamble right
it could pay off if we find care for
something it would it could be fine it's
basically a two cash gamble to hold it
yeah
it doesn't delay
design so it it wouldn't be a disaster
too yeah
well on the flashlight I have enough
he's actually going
yeah
surprise surprise
okay play design
you should have bumped twice before
right nah because if he if he takes the
first one I'll just get the second one
right it doesn't matter yeah but maybe
he has a way to get to but yeah in the
end yeah indeed yeah
with this perfect play I put my water on
the free heat and now I can get the bump
easy gaming
I'm very very good at this game
foreign
number three yeah I think so
wow this is such a hard choice
what do you think master
you're going poor or two
connection
can I look
yeah of course sure
[Music]
I I'm not sure they're Meister I don't
agree it could be two
this is going so fast right
it's this is gonna
be online gen
six seven at the lighter I think
seven in the latest yeah
that's very good for him
but on the other hand
yeah yeah I agree it could be four yeah
it kind of moves but so my decision is
either decomposers for farming
um probably into farming or is ecopos
just too good to pass up no no you don't
care about decomposers nobody of you is
doing engine here farming is too much
fun it's funny
because we'll get online
soon
unless yours heat which you shouldn't
so nothing to do you can take you you
can take number one as well you have
nothing to do right so the number one is
fine so like this
yeah yeah
I can even take the ocean right
why not just put it on here now uh
like it's like oh yeah look at the ocean
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's it's
okay it's okay if you want to do it you
can also go for a card but also start
taking some plants up here or two
titanium
if I get this I can convert with this
next gen without the plants right now so
I think I'll take the two titanium
yeah it depends if you found yeah I
think the titanium makes sense
all right
we're completely Reliant
no he wants my Milestone
he's learned from yesterday
so what I'm calculating is I can either
give him the bonus now he's gonna take
the bonus at the start of the Next
Generation should I just take the this
one now since I'm passing before him
he always has it right I like the I like
the titanium over here
Meister
[Music]
okay uh what is this plan situation
he's got one plant production
yeah restricted he played
some boomi stuff
[Music]
but I'm assuming since he made this play
I'm assuming he has one more special
title oh [\h__\h]
yeah wait uh this is pretty important uh
how many jobs has he played maybe
flooding uh is he really getting jobims
just because of Miranda result
Miranda at all he actually has he
actually has enough cash to play it if
you want to
yeah
huh should we just take it up no this is
useless for you I mean I would take
business contacts I think but uh yeah I
give passing him that ensures that he
will play it probably but then if he
plays it you get the
you get the polar Explorer Milestone but
yeah I think it's business we need to
find Pentax and the first one is useless
for us
oh no I had this discussion yesterday do
I really play micro Mills I really don't
want to no you don't why would you nice
because why would you need it I mean we
were talking about yesterday do we go
the DJ way here
yeah it's good only
if you if you get it online gen one or
two and it gives you a heat bump at some
point but uh here that's not the case
you have 13 hit Rod you don't need a
14-ft run for six cash no problem
hmm
[Music]
hey Highlander
uh numbers no wait no it's number three
okay
these power start
s this
no no no take number three as well do we
skip this yeah now myself would you
so is it taking my milestone
or is he taking the German amplifier
it's a question if he wants to play IO
and I think he wants to play IO he will
have to uh
to for to to let you take the polar
Explorer Milestone there's no way you
can get good for sure
uh so you only get one Milestone here
but
that's all right
I can get I can get polar as well for
sure because he doesn't take it yeah you
get Polo Explorer but he gets the rest
ah Maybe
I mean if I do this I can't use the
action
[Music]
yeah let's go to DJing way I like it
here he's playing Joe's on Harris
[Music]
Gen4 I like it so much
I mean
yeah he did it it's okay you you've got
your conversion you convert with Hydro I
can convert here or here this will just
give me enough plans is this better than
where
sorry where do you want to convert I can
do it either here or here like in the
long term it feels like I cannot see
your pointer okay so I can I can get uh
conversion by placing water next to the
water or I can do it on the top left
uh I would take the rebates I think
there's no value in one extra plan at
the moment so I would take the rebate
probably yeah
uh do you have do we have another ocean
in hand
no yeah and it's a bit
[Music]
so do this I do yeah yeah yeah you can
what the hell is this side is this city
did I put down the city
there is restricted and there's mining
area that's what you type
what is this is this not a city
no which one okay
it's not it's no I don't play any City
uh
uh it doesn't matter back to the card
maybe yeah knock to the card next to the
card no next to your city and next to
the card right through your city but
yeah
[Music]
so this is it
how much cash does he have
I have two cash yeah that's why it's the
city holy hell not bad so you don't have
to find it you can tap him
yeah I can wait
no okay
you can tap him now all right yeah
yeah sure no no respect no respect for
you and Mike Jones
[Music]
but the question is is there anything I
want to do with my cash other than just
starting their work I could do business
contacts I guess I would rip business
just do
have some information
okay that's actually very nice
uh I'll do this and then I'm considering
number one of course yeah
wait wait wait that's not a clear cut to
me how many science do we have I have
two we have zero right we have two why
would you like consider any other card
here yeah yeah that's true who cares
about the car number two
[Music]
it doesn't matter
so the question is
I might as well just take the this
number yeah you can take it
then you can just take it yeah he'd done
twice and pass yes
[Music]
okay so now I need a science tag I just
take this I think no I don't think we
play it uh what we could play it but if
you want but
I agree it's decent here
oh this is interesting maybe this
no no I think we got Phobos right yeah
three titanium crops yeah you should
think yeah
really it's also attacks it's baseball
like he has he has titanium prod and he
doesn't heal control right and he has
four yeah and Commercial is a bad card
usually so
uh why magnetic fields magnetic field is
trash
dirty grades can also can always enable
Advanced ecosystems or something okay
there is more Synergy with another great
all right so I have 27
plus three that's 30. I can only keep
this right yeah but it's it's okay you
don't want more yeah I don't think we
you wanna speculate on it what
particularly somewhat
I think
oh yeah you're asking for your hand yeah
I don't know I would maybe keep it but
can you show your text I didn't even
watch you I mean we have just one so I
I think it's not I think I wouldn't hear
because you both have hit and like it's
doing nothing for you I think he's with
me yeah
I agree
okay
there we go
[Music]
okay yeah decent yeah I mean I thought
your people were like Tempo nerds and
stuff and here I am playing AI Central
and here he is playing Joven amplifies
when both of us are going for temples
it's perfectly fine you need to gain to
give yourself some sailing yeah
literally in the can oh nice we got this
it's a nice Cut I think this can yeah
okay
[Music]
uh what what is the award situation I
don't even remember what did you award
from this man
the cultivator magnet spaceborne yeah I
don't think I'm calling anything no
there's nothing I might look at this at
some point
no he has he he has everything he has
all the Milestones you can do nothing
about it hmm
[Music]
I only need two more I'm not sure
I'll be the only if you want to have
diversifier a new group settle D okay
drop two
yeah card four is decent but it's it's
got two here
I agree
oh what about this oh okay keep cut four
I think this is pretty good I mean I
don't think this is
do you think this is worth it home also
I'm not sure
take out four count four is good for us
yeah
we have a
we have a ECF now
oh [\h__\h] what about you like oh no I
think I think the other card do you like
this do you like regular light here
I don't think the other card was good
but less we don't we have no interest in
developing the bumper when we have ai
Central we have good scaling and we have
some plant fraud waiting I think the
bumper is country predicted I think it's
I think it's good here actually I'm not
sure because he has more engine than me
but maybe you're right
does he you have more draw that's what
matters yeah yeah you don't have license
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no not this one the other
one
two three yeah
oh this is actually nice for me
yes
one right
[Music]
I don't think I'm in rush to do anything
I'll just throw some cards here
yeah
unless there's something urgent
also one oh no that's not playable oh
shame one time you uh boneless because I
mentioned I noticed that you usually do
random one actions people usually don't
like that just yeah
sure I have to I have to get used to
this yeah here one action didn't make
any sense no the only the only reason is
I have 18 minutes left and I have no
idea what to do that's actually though
but I guess uh what we're doing here is
uh
I could I could convert with this but I
don't know I could also just pass to be
honest what do you think all right
oh what about this I can play farming no
no it's not that farming oh no no no
that costs too much
wait wait wait wait you can actually if
you want to do it
you can actually do the card number
eight the last card you see oh yeah
right and then play the card you drew
but uh I'm not sure it's worth it it
might be it might not be which card
which
cards
we can enable it with this I'm not sure
it's what I think I like it I think it
is I think it is it also enables card
number one one jumpsuiter probably yeah
I think it's decent uh it would be
greater to go well first so I think I'll
skip one yeah
yeah
obviously bumps the heat yeah that was a
I didn't see this play good call
that gave me something to do this
generation otherwise I could have just
passed
that thing was fine as well but um
I think it's fine but
um it's fine and you basically force him
to claim Rim settler here which is good
yeah
I can convert but I can just wait what
do you think you wait you wait your
priority is to play card number one yeah
and uh playing that card eventually for
now I forgot to bump but I guess one two
it's okay not too bum because you give
him control if he gets for example
something to pump then you will but I'm
gonna start next gen I don't know I I
feel like I could have bumped and it
would be okay when he has no cash
you can make one yeah but I mean you
don't know it will that be the case if
you bump you give him the the ocean then
if he has Duke Zone a big asteroid lava
flow that's just too many cars I
wouldn't have bumped and I think it's
correct not to dump you all right
yeah look at this
definitely
all right yeah
uh I also works for this if I want to
and this is not bad
holy hell
yeah yeah this is very strong man
um interesting actually
I think it is God number four but uh
I like both I'm not sure about this one
for eccentric reasons especially
no
all right
[Music]
yeah
doesn't matter what wait wait like yeah
yeah I know I was just thinking
so like this one what did he Pat what
did he take for investment flow
I'm confused about that too why don't
you the garage
makes sense he has three titanium prod
man
okay yeah like it's better
that hello
so here would be a really good time for
me to to slow play take one action per
turn so wait no no no don't take one
action is very rude
you can you can uh you can pump once if
he has something to take it he has
something to take it and if he doesn't
then you understand I think you could
just end up on it together
he doesn't want to do that probably yeah
yeah he doesn't have enough cash
like yeah okay so this is situation okay
so let's explain this situation yeah
you always have uh hit brought here and
he has hit prod it doesn't make sense
that he wants to SP out to get one bonus
point because he's pretty poor and he
wants to do other things right so
basically that ocean is important but
it's not that important that USB out for
it because other parameters are like you
both have enough heat it will not
selection easily so like I don't know
exactly and if you if you just do one
heat bump here you're saying to him okay
if you don't have big asteroid if you
don't have nuke Zone if you don't have
lava flows I will take this on my next
turn so you're putting pressure on it
and there is value in that so yeah but
on the other hand I think our standard
project for him every day because he's
getting the bonus and that means I'm not
and I can get it for free I have I have
enough heat together yeah but that's 14
for two points okay
it's average if yes also you really want
to be playing your card number one so
you really want the the yeah at zero uh
this gen so
I don't know if I was him I think I
would take this so I don't get it but
let's see what maybe he will get it but
it's fine if he gets it it's it's it's
okay but it's not crazy value
yeah
he probably has
if he takes it it's good but it also
delays on development he has in his hand
well yeah okay
yeah get it anyway so so no there's no
point now I just do this
I have to get the last yeah that's
worked
don't forget to pick up number seven
before God number one
you don't get the lies though because he
has inspection but yeah
oh I was confused why do I still have
seven
card number seven your card number seven
yeah
let's see
card number seven yeah so this and this
yeah
yeah seven and one I can convert now
probably convert first yeah yeah on the
card
can you show me your hand first sorry I
can also Loom
but I don't think I can get enough heat
to take the last Heat I think I can
I think I just converted on the card you
can you can but I mean I don't know if
it's worked but you can because you have
that card as well
maybe it's maybe it's it is enough if
you convert
show me the map okay that's a good
person you can convert next to yeah and
it's probably like you get the point no
not there that's your city yeah yeah
I think it's fine so now I can load heat
travels farming and maybe convert again
is that what
the plan is
no to take the last key bump
you can never take that what do you want
him to I'm not sure about either how do
I take the last tip up
with the fifth card
but you don't have to you don't have to
oh yeah yeah I think it's bad I don't
think it's worth it yeah I'm not sure
but it delays it delays farming and
farming yeah you can do yeah do do that
car do the card number one no do the
loan no no no no no loan first yeah
number one
yeah
and then third one and play card eight
probably now seven Sorry Seven
yeah
yeah I think this is a better idea then
the other play
yeah it is better for sure
you can do uh even
let's see uh
Ironworks or power grid yeah both are
dead yeah
yeah do that
I think I like this better because I I
have I have a lot of things now right
now I can use this to get two animals
Maybe
uh yeah don't don't don't don't you may
need to end the game at some point and
it gives you I will talk with you plans
here because there is yeah as well and
you can do it right away
I wouldn't I would wait yeah there's no
point in doing it now I'm just saying
later in the game I might take the fish
that's all I'm saying
man you've got all the premium cars here
wait uh what has he done show his
Scotland
what has he done
oh he has played
uh this is dangerous to pass him solo
wind power
yeah it's basically free from him
yeah but
I can I can
I don't care
it's not that important I can take this
I think it's sort of wind power he has
no power he may want some
this probably
yeah it's the only card that matters the
rest is
and playable
I mean uh uh and then it doesn't matter
yeah this one yeah
I mean a good technically play it but
it's not good isn't it
um
I think I'd rather nah
there's no way I'm playing this way
no no way of course not
um there is no way you're playing that
as well I think yeah I think card number
two is even bad to be honest
yeah yeah it's not good you have two
oceans
why kids are good he will probably put
an ocean at some point and if he does
that then you just bought a dead cried
so I just did nothing
I I would keep known yeah I'm zero
whatever 10 minutes I think we can make
it in two generations should be okay
what about this now
I'm really liking this he got silver
playing production this guys
in Texas out insects is still in the
game anyway it's still in the game but
it's pretty bad uh I think you have
nothing better to I would draw first
with AI and then you can find if you
want I think because I have plan
production I have so many so much
planned in my hand if you wonder I think
it's okay what did you draw oh that's
credible
I don't think that's good there are cats
it's not great
you should find yeah yeah I think it's
okay yeah
[Music]
hell is game where he gets finished by
gen seven
[Music]
I think looking at my place I don't
really have anything useful to do right
now
nope maybe just this or maybe this I
mean this can wait
but I don't see I don't see anything I
can really do
would you play artificial here Islander
I would I think I would as well but as
you if we play artificial it's better to
wait until next gen and then Earth
catapult artificial no I don't think
you're all you're ever playing your
scatter balls I mean we have ai Central
we may be playing it but it's very
marginal
uh
I think I yeah yeah I think I think I'll
just pass and see you next gen yeah but
uh if you played before catapult you are
not losing anything because you're in
production I would play artificial I
would play artificial on two plants for
cash in the Northeast
I would do it yeah
uh so it was hmm
oh okay now it looks better please oh
did you put my pants
he's listening to us
now it's dead wait so I mean maybe this
next year
it's better than nothing I know I I know
I passed artificial Lake yeah
we know that you know
you should play now because you should
play it yeah yeah really what about this
no it doesn't matter
is good value in any case and he may if
you don't play artificial now he may
play an ocean and you will lose value on
everything so yeah it's just better to
take the ocean get full cash back get
two plants and convert so yeah over here
uh doesn't matter
uh wait wait it could matter uh
I would
I would go north I think Northeast what
do you think Highlander I would do
I'm not sure I think that the Western
spot may be better because it might ruin
if he wants to get something there like
a city or something it ruins a bit it
also makes a better attack for it but
yeah I think he goes in the other side I
think it's completely the same
I'll just convert
yeah convert on the card I guess
uh yeah you can convert on the card or I
can next to my city but
I think when the card is fine
you want cars here especially since we
said already that you drew or it's
capable so if you want to play it maybe
we will see next gen but I'm not sure
yeah I think I'm passing now
[Music]
okay we have to hurry yeah
um
this is very close oh he he has a
regular I didn't see that yes how did I
miss that
oh
okay so this looks cool yeah definitely
definitely card number two yeah I think
so
well whoa wait wait wait don't don't uh
how many plan tax does it have
two I got two
yeah
I think you should cut that I think you
you cut it but you don't take it
this doesn't matter
yeah I mean playable yeah
maybe even good for you I'm not sure I
can also Gamble and see if I get the
last plant tag but I no I have no
titanium production it's probably better
I would take out number three card
number three is good
and card number one yeah
okay yep
I forgot to go about insulation here
right yeah
you could do installation yeah
you can draw yeah uh no I do you can
play Herbies as well yeah divorce
convert no
therapy words you want to see actually I
think yeah there's no rush on conversion
right the heat is maxed so there's no
rush on converting I would draw and play
herbivores yeah and let's see what has
to oh he has one okay
it's too late
I have six minutes man I have to I have
to act
yeah but you know if you wanted to play
your stats then you just lost quite a
bit of cash
and we lost on this no because we didn't
talk with our cards yeah yeah
oh I think I think I could start
eccentric
not yet not yet all right
yeah it's difficult with him having uh
ECF so play
okay do we want to play yeah we probably
do one tomorrow
yeah and then converts something like
this I could also Play My City
no no you you build up the city and then
convert yeah yeah definitely
I agree
question is do I have I have uh money to
city and then ecozone and then convert
there's no rush on ecozone
North
I would play the city north west near
one ocean and convert for four cash back
and two points yeah yeah it looks good
yeah on one plant and then covers
not okay you can do it but I think that
the other spot was much better because
then you can convert South and then you
can equal Zone on the card in the plant
I think that was better oh here
uh yeah actually yeah yeah yeah
Highlander is right like I think this is
very decent as well it's fine and it
doesn't matter I like the idea with the
ecosone here but I guess it doesn't
matter that much
hmm
so this will be very close yeah for sure
he may be trying to end this Gem and win
actually maybe playing earthcad for this
reason was a mistake
yes
to greeneries he may be trying to
surprise win here
uh
what is the award situation how is
Centric for sure
yeah but he probably has space bearing
right
yeah but that's another reason I should
start eccentric now right
You're Expecting if you can't end like
then you're dead
yeah if if he and now you're dead for
sure
if if he ends now we win if we don't
play earthcat and we play large Convoy
instead but uh
if you can now I think we did
yeah good pun
in any case right now I think eccentric
is correct I don't think I have any no
no no no no no no yes yes yes yes yes
yes let's use it right now
did he use it of course he did right
which one yeah yeah he used it uh
extreme cold fungus okay
this is I think eccentric is way too
dangerous but
you just need to think will he you have
low concrete trapping I would always
find like look at The Eccentric local
kids yeah okay yeah yeah okay do it I
really want to escape here I don't know
what to do uh local keep helping local
heat wrapping into fish right
yeah sure I mean the plan could be
important but
yeah
what about the cultivator Can you steal
that
thing
um
but this whole last generation here this
is just another reason why it's uh it
feels more natural to me to like slow
play a little bit you know what I mean
like right now I'm I'm anxious I don't
know if he's gonna
that's why you can you can stall a bit
to see what he does so we have cards to
sell so that's fine
but this will still be rude no
no one car no in the last generation
yeah yeah oh in the last generation I'm
allowed okay
it's okay not to do it in the last
generation
yeah I mean it's not it's not great if
this is not the last generation so you
lose a bit of Advantage you will have
but on the other hand you'll still have
ai Central which means you have some
actions going
so tight
for you usually you shouldn't sell your
cards before the last jet
right yes unless I want to stall to see
if this yeah but even if you want to
stall because you'll gain by stalling uh
earlier but then you lose those stalls
later right yeah and so later it matters
more so yeah and later matters more yeah
but the thing is if you can end now
somehow then I should have stalled now
so I can play I don't know ecosystem or
something yeah of course now it's fine
to stall because you
you don't know if he ends so it's
completely reasonable take your action
and sell one card and that's fine
no I did I did one oh okay oh so we give
it back then
Jesus Christ all these gentlemen
agreements stressing me out guys
actually
the the installation play I forget it to
play it less than cost me the game here
yeah I think that the installation was
plus five I think we made a mistake as
well on three I think if we don't play
earthcat we always win yeah it might be
a good point uh yeah I mean there is no
way for me to to actually win here only
way I win is I flip
cultivator I type I Thai cultivator
which I can actually do
but I don't have enough money for birds
I also think it was a mistake to
play uh the hit so early on anymore
yeah I think so too you should have
stalled here I mean
yeah but I mean that's the thing is I've
been learning from you guys today and
yesterday I think
playing earthcat was a mistake I think
we definitely lost some points on the
herbivores play before yeah
but I mean yeah yeah but if we end up
not playing ecozone and if we hadn't
played our scan obviously playing
herbivores it's not a mistake but uh
yeah
I don't know it feels like this game was
uh earthquake was a mistake for sure but
it also feels like this game was
easy winning if we just all a little
let's see oh my God Predators all right
yeah now it's a problem
yeah it's a problem for eccentric for
sure so I can I can sell three cars play
ecozone or I can just
yeah I mean that's install action so
this this is okay I can I can bump a
maxed heat and this is a nobody raising
my library really yeah no
you just don't do it with when turtle is
just funded yeah you can do it now so do
it once once or twice what are we doing
here what did he do he took one action
I'm gonna ask him
no you should you should think he can he
ends
he can and if he has
inflation he's not ending so you can
even pass now I think
yeah
and savior still actions for Action yeah
agreed
all right and save your time in three
minutes as well yeah you're fine you're
fine three minutes three minutes is
plenty enough yeah
[Music]
um
he doesn't have no he doesn't have cash
Meister oh
okay three plants on that one
four plans four plants might be enough
to take this I think it's fine like the
others do nothing
yeah it should be a Greenery which is
fine yeah I don't care
does he have power does he have power
he doesn't
ah honestly cup number two is bad even
for him it costs 21 for two points what
is he going to do with 21 for two points
I would cut peroxide yeah peroxide yeah
yep that's a point we'll do a bad point
uh there is a contractor here there is a
contractor I guess he's funding before I
am number one is fine what
I think it's fine to do it's probably
Greenery not not card number three I
wouldn't I wouldn't do it okay
yeah just one yeah
it should be green Reese unless he has
Birds
maybe maybe I just protect my cultivator
instead of starting contractor
probably better
you don't find contractor right by how
much are you leading tractor I'm leading
by two yeah no it's not possible to do
it this was interesting
all right he wants my he wants my
cultivator that's what's happening yeah
it's probably his only shot at winning
okay
and one action or two actions
take your fish yes
what you need to do when he plays
see what we drew see what we drew we got
the greenhouses it's a good car
greenhouses it's decent actually this
might actually be playable
yeah it is okay as well
[Music]
this corporate stronghold was not good
stall
baby
I would honestly play my points and let
him end if he can end
yeah I agree
no uh play the the Convoy for sleeping
yeah but wait wait wait
because cultivator is Imperial but so is
eccentric here yeah
so what are we doing with the large
Convoy
it's harder for him to get culture I
mean I don't know yeah you can actually
take eccentric he hasn't used this yet I
don't think
yeah I think eccentric is in a bigger
danger so take fish take fish with large
combo yeah it's more points with large
Cambrian fish yeah
[Music]
yeah
what did we draw see what we draw
okay
I think it's this this this this this
this this pass you are doing
you're doing equal Zone
you're doing ecozone
what about a city here
some you don't have cash for a city you
don't have cash for a city and it's bad
you're doing equal Zone on uh on one
plant East
and two cash yeah definitely yeah
yeah
yep dual animals animals of course yeah
animals obviously
so now my essentially should be safe you
take greenhouses as well yeah you can
sell first but you can sell first okay
you have to worry because the game is
not ending here you have to hurry yeah
so you're doing oh [\h__\h] greenhouses
yeah it's it's not a meme your
Greenhouse is you're insects and you
pass yeah
holy hell it's not ending now I feel
stressed
greenhouses
and uh insects insects
that's that's defense cultivator as well
probably
yeah
because you have to I didn't honestly I
can sell three cards just to play
windmills but
depends can you end in the end
yeah I think I'll just do that yeah
yeah
oh it's so close hurry hurry hurry hurry
because you know if he decides not to
end you're in trouble here because of
the timer
answer and played yeah
[Music]
this is very close
yeah but he can't sleep uh neither of
the two
you can type maybe maybe he can tie a
motivator which would be enough right
yeah because uh you have two two tiles
if he kills your tile
but he can't kill a tile and
fight right he doesn't have enough cash
I don't know how many can he see when we
Birds no he doesn't have enough yeah so
you're probably fine even if he does
that you you he can flip them
no he has Birds yeah he'll play Birds he
play Birds yeah and kelp kelp is a
conversion for him right
now
thank you
yeah we're going to time out
uh Heather yes bike Heather bite bite
yeah I'll just play fast now I think I'm
yeah just play fast you're fine you the
game ends
yeah I think you convert you start with
the conversion converting contract
that's what I'm thinking depending on no
don't fun don't fun um
hurry hurry
up I'm not sure yes see it doesn't
matter
I think so too
convert and drop
yeah convert on two planes two plants
draw yeah draw with a guy
hurry hurry hurry hurry yeah you you
have to pay really fast yeah no time to
think oh nice uh I don't know guys with
this I really wanna play three together
treat Heather take your fish okay the
last one all right yeah all right trees
Heather
yes
don't convert yet because it is
what why not convert
you can play your migrendo right playing
immigrant is fine yeah
where here
um
play Soul Factory take your fish and
pass and you should really if you don't
have 20 seconds you will time out at the
end if he wants to feel cultivated no no
no no it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter you take immigrants yeah yeah so
Pottery Factory no so far
[Music]
I don't know
okay Soul Factory fish pass yeah
doesn't matter it doesn't matter yeah
okay maybe matters for yeah maybe
yeah so don't sell just pass yeah don't
sell yeah you don't have time for
selling all right
[Music]
you should take one plant yes yes
okay you're not timing out
all right yeah I agree with you like
amazing by the way this is why I wanted
to take a Greenery instead of the
immigracy you see this now he's flipping
culture
yeah
he doesn't flip it it's fine well he
gets he gets a tie right
oh maybe he doesn't are we even oh [\h__\h]
I win it still
and next to the city now
and you win
I should have blocked you with uh
I should have blocked your uh yeah you
should get I I realized when I said that
that you can still do it
like what
she could block your conversion oh yeah
he could to make sure I didn't get one
more Greenery there would have been
enough actually and that's actually I
think if we had played immigrants on the
planet
it was it it were better it could have
been a sure win for us yeah but there
was a problem because there was no uh a
Greenery yet there so if we play
Immigrant before he can urbanize us we
don't we don't know if he took it we
best urbanized yeah that is true
I think the safest place would be to not
play uh immigrant City and just use that
money to make it like Greenery but I'm
not sure I mean it's gonna be really
close
you lose if you do that
yeah I guess but only uh
um I was just afraid he would take the
cultivator for me but I see that I got
it now
but okay holy hell it was fun I really
have to go see ya see ya
it was a nice game for sure yeah yeah I
mean we are we are talking and do this
do this but I hope you understand the
decisions where we say something and
you'll see why it's good yeah for sure
that's important to understand
I wanted if if I would have played the
five cash board for project nine I had
an easy win that would have been very
interesting uh play
yeah if you played your installation
yeah yeah if I played insulation I think
right I can end yeah yeah because uh and
I can end and play birds and I tie uh
cultivator
cultivator yeah
yeah I agree
oh well fun game though yeah really fun
game thanks for playing
yeah yeah sure anytime